hello rit canada or e.t
canada you know you guys are really good
to me are we
yes we are no you are definitely even
better than et america like i always see
et canada stuff
is that because of you no it's not
because of me it's because of our
award-winning team
all right i appreciate that yeah i'm not
sick i just uh yeah i know it's okay
it's my pride
well first of all you are a part of so
many disney projects are you like the
coolest dad ever
no well
it's i'm working on it believe me i i've
tried to i think i you know get him to
think i'm cool for about four or five
years now for four years he we were
driving the other day hand to god and
kokomo comes on the radio and i go isn't
that cool your dad played on kokomo the
beach boys he's like that's what it goes
dad um
takes as long as me do you know the
beatles
but
he loved he was a big fan of
mickey mouse funhouse then i did a voice
on their new voice on there
called salty bones right pirate
and then i do then he moved on to
fighting his amazing friends and then i
got a job on there playing iron man so
that's cool you are a cool dad and it's
first day of school
yeah first day of pre-pre-k and i took
him a lot because my wife was working so
we were he says dad i don't you don't
have to walk me in like the first day
i'm
bawling and he walks okay bye dad and
like walks and i swear i saw a little
tiny middle finger
but he's
fine
[Music]
well congratulations on everything and i
think you're a cool dad big shot season
two's coming up
oh i don't know what you guys do in
canada but you know over here we're
ready we yeah big shot season
october 12th
and all 10 episodes are going to drop at
one time
and i think it's gonna be cool you've
never seen the show but it's a good one
it's going to be good
okay love it thank you